death to Black Friday that's the story
we've heard as the rise in Cyber Monday
grows in popularity some Shoppers say
that is the case While others say the
traditional in-person shopping is here
to stay I'm all in that 20 people in on
a timer just hours after a turkey Feast
I've never had a line this long before
just to get in Lululemon
Shoppers got back on the road first 50
people get more sales for a tradition
that some say is dying off that's
something very special knowing that
there aren't going to be delays in
online shipping and things like that but
Black Friday began back in October for
big box stores like Target coals and
Walmart supply chain concerns and too
much inventory partly why and a Shoppers
increasingly choose to sleep in Friday
ahead of Cyber Monday
and while the tradition's not gone yet
it's like more traditional so I like it
it is changing the mesas were among
hundreds shopping through the Las Vegas
North Premium Outlets Friday morning a
lot of the stores they don't they don't
do the whole thing where they'll open at
12 a.m you know though now they wait
till six in the morning unfortunately in
the middle of the night our building had
a catastrophic event and we had a fire
and others like Carolyn spolitini
searching for Deals they didn't think
they'd need at the end of the day you
have to look at everything where's the
silver lining the Silver Lining is
fortunately it's Black Friday Best Buy
is right around the corner they've got
fantastic awesome awesome deals today
and we'll be up and running in 24 hours
the national retail Federation says over
166 million Americans will go shopping
this weekend gift cards are a favorite
gift this holiday season expectation of
over 28 billion dollars will be spent on
gift cards this year and the most
popular gift cards are for restaurants
at 27 followed by department stores at
26 25 want Bank issued cards and then 10
will go towards food